There are many things "The Batman" gets right
about its title character.
So what's the deal with that super-slow walk?
Keep watching to find out.
Heads up — spoilers ahead!
The Caped Crusader begins the film as a terrifying
creature of the night, instilling fear into
the hearts of criminals and everyday citizens
alike.
"Fear is a tool."
However, he realizes he needs to be more than
that by the end of the movie.
He needs to be a symbol of hope as much as
fear.
Another aspect the film does exceptionally
well is establishing Bruce Wayne as the world's
greatest detective, as he's often referred
to in the comics.
He walks slowly around crime scenes, taking
in every detail.
And when he receives his first card from Riddler,
he's able to solve the riddle fairly quickly.
He's met his intellectual match, but before
he can bring Riddler to justice, he'll go
through the physical and emotional wringer
to realize what he needs to become to stop
him.
"I'm vengeance."
It's unlike any other Batman film that's come
before, and some of the changes to the character
and setting have some fans scratching their
heads.
One of the most significant changes involves
the speed at which Batman enters a crime scene
— many viewers have noted he walks exceptionally
slowly entering a room.
This has caused quite a stir on social media,
particularly on Reddit.
However, many fans have chimed in with their
own theories as to why this Batman is slower
than what we've seen on the big screen before.
One Reddit user posted a meme reading,
"Batman in this movie walks slowly when entering
crime scenes so that his lens can record and
identify details with greater clarity."
One of the newest gadgets Batman sports in
the new movie is a pair of high-tech contact
lenses that record everything the user looks
at.
It allows Bruce to review the footage at a
later time so he can focus on small details
he and the cops may have missed the first
time around.
He also gives the lenses to Selina Kyle at
one point so that he can look at the clientele
deep within Penguin's club.
In fact, the same Reddit user made a great
connection, stating,
"This is also shown canonically when he requests
Selina to move around a bit slower as he's
tracking everyone's face inside the lounge."
Of course, others suggest the slow walking
goes even deeper.
A different Reddit user wrote,
"It also makes him seem even more inhuman
and unnatural lends to his terror hero status."
Both explanations ring true, and it just goes
to show the level of detail director Matt
Reeves went into crafting a realistic world.
"The first conversation I had with Matt about
it, I just knew there was something radically
different from anything we'd seen in Batman
movies before."
Throughout his existence, Batman has always
sported an array of gadgets to help him out
of a bind.
He may not have superpowers, but he has plenty
of help in other ways.
In "The Batman," he has a few familiar gadgets,
but there are some new items, as well, that
assist him when he needs them most.
Arguably, the most important gadget he has
at his disposal outside of the contact lenses
is the liquid he injects himself with during
the final battle with Riddler's henchmen.
It's never established what precisely the
substance is.
Some believe it was a mere adrenaline shot
Batman uses whenever he's too beaten and bruised
to continue on his own.
Others think it was a variation of Bane's
Venom, either establishing that Bane already
exists in this universe or that he could potentially
come up down the road.
One of the Reddit users in the latter category
said,
"I'm glad I wasn't the only one who noticed
the serum.
I think they're setting up for Bane.
His reaction to it was very reminiscent of
how Bane would react."
While much of his gear has been seen in other
iterations of the character, "The Batman"
adds some intriguing wrinkles here and there
to make the machines more practical to this
particular version.
For instance, Batman has seemingly always
had a grappling gun, but this version springs
out of his arm for quick and easy access.
Perhaps another reason why Batman walks slowly
is due to all the gear he has to carry around
with him!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.